This is inside the cockpit of NASA’s operation
IceBridge, the largest airborne survey of
Earth’s polar ice ever flown.
The scientists aboard are hunkered down in
their command stations, gathering critical
measurements on thinning sea ice, shrinking
glaciers, and calving ice shelves.
Flying in 8-12 hour shifts, multiple days
a week, they’re taking the vital signs of
the Arctic.
It’s an unprecedented, birds eye view of
what climate change actually looks like.
Temperatures in the Arctic have been rising
about to two to three times the global average.
So over the next century, we expect Greenland
to experience a lot warmer temperatures, continue
to melt, and then continue to raise sea level.
That’s Nathan Kurtz, a project scientist
with Operation IceBridge.
He’s part of a team of over 30 glaciologists,
engineers, and pilots who survey the massive
ice sheets in Antarctica and Greenland on
this flying laboratory.
We probably do 60 to 70 flights per year.
Then once we're up in the air, we transit
at high altitude but then we'll descend down
to low altitude, so 1500 feet.
The P-3 in particular is meant to fly low
and slow.
First constructed during the cold war to track
Russian submarines, the P-3 is an ideal reconnaissance
aircraft for polar surveys.
The crew will follow a meticulously planned
flight path, with specific targets in mind.
The goal is to create a consistent and continuous
data stream of the changing ice, bridging
the gap between the decommissioned ICESat
satellite and the ICESat-2 that’s expected
to launch in 2018.
Hence the name, Operation IceBridge.
The P-3 is outfitted with a suite of instruments
-- and one of the most critical is the laser
altimeter.
It shoots out tiny green pulses straight at
the ice sheet.
Along with laser altimeters, there are radar
instruments, GPS, gravimeters, and of course,
a digital camera system that captures images
of the terrain below.
We're measuring how thick the ice is in total,
and then mapping what the rock structure is
underneath the ice.
These tools reveal what’s invisible to the
naked eye, transforming Greenland’s massive
ice sheet into a 3D picture with incredible
detail.
We're trying to figure out how the surface
changed year to year to year, and so Helheim,
what's called the calving fronts of the end
of the glacier, has been retreating for quite
a while.
And out of the nearly ten years of flying
zigzagging patterns across the poles, the
data points to an irreversible trend.
We’ve had large changes in sea ice, and
this is changing the albedo of the surface
so sea ice is bright, reflects a lot of the
sun's energy, but as the Arctic has been warming
we’ve been seeing a decrease in the amount
of ice, and that in turn exposes open ocean,
which absorbs more of the sun's energy.
This feedback loop is what keeps scientists
like Nathan coming back to the poles for month-long
missions.
Retreating sea ice will increase global temperatures,
which leads to widespread surface melting
of Greenland's ice sheet.
The amount of ice that’s on Greenland, if
it were all to melt could raise sea level
by something like 8 meters, so over 20 feet.
Basically, Nathan wants to arm the people
in charge of making huge environmental decisions
with the facts.
And all of the data collected during each
flight mission is actionable.
They help climate scientists more accurately
predict how the poles could change in the
future; because even though the ice looks
peaceful from above, there’s a whole other
story underneath.
For more science documentaries, check out
this one right.
Don't forget to subscribe and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos.